dass die sonne heller scheint als der
mond das weiß doch eigentlich jedes kind
das stimmt aber nur eingeschränkt und
zwar übertrifft der mond die sonne an
strahlungsintensität sehr deutlich wenn
wir ihn im bereich der gammastrahlen
sehen genau davon sind einem
forschungsteam jetzt mit hilfe des fermi
gamma ray space teleskops der nasa
wirklich spektakuläre aufnahmen gelungen
doch diese strahlung bedeutet ein großes
risiko für zukünftige mond
astronautinnen und astronauten klick zum
salzen fiction hier gibt's täglich
faszinierendes seines videos abonniert
den kanal aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen auf den ersten blick könnte
man meinen es handelt sich bei dieser
aufnahme um conny die rote pixel und ja
dieses rote leuchten des mond sieht
nicht nur ziemlich spooky sondern auch
total unwirklich aus kein wunder denn
das menschliche auge ist normalerweise
gar nicht in der lage diese art von
strahlung wahrzunehmen konkret handelt
es sich um die sogenannte gamma
strahlung des mondes mit hilfe des fermi
gamma ray space teleskops fgs c der nasa
gelang es jetzt dieses leuchten
einzufangen dieses weltraum teleskop
soll astronomie teams weltweit dabei
helfen die quellen von hoch
energetischen gammastrahlen aufzuspüren
beispielsweise schwarze löcher puhl sara
gammablitze flairs der sonne oder aber
supernova überreste auch das
forschungsteam aus italien ist daran
interessiert die hoch energetische
kosmische strahlung im detail zu
verstehen und nicht nur für die fachwelt
ist klar dass die aufnahmen des mondes
im bereich der gammastrahlen reichlich
spektakulär sind wenn sie zeigen etwas
was im widerspruch zu unseren bisherigen
vorstellungen vom mond steht denen er
zufolge deutlich weniger scheint als die
sonne doch anders in diesem bestimmten
teil des elektromagnetischen spektrums
hier leuchtet der mond eben heller als
die sonne heißt also im klartext der
mond sendet mehr gammastrahlung aus als
die sonne die den großteil ihrer energie
in anderen teilen des spektrums
produziert doch natürlich bleibt es
dabei dass auch sie gammastrahlen abgibt
vor allem bei sonneneruptionen auch bei
anderen extremen ereignissen im kosmos
wird gammastrahlung die hauptsächlich
aus protonen besteht freigesetzt dazu
der astronom mario nicola mazzotta der
an der aktuellen studie beteiligt war
kosmische
besteht hauptsächlich aus protonen die
durch einige der energetischen phänomene
des universums beschleunigt werden wie
die wellen explodierende sterne und jets
die entstehen wenn materien schwarze
löcher fällt diese art von strahlung
ermöglicht ist zwar fachleuten nicht die
oberflächenstrukturen von himmelskörpern
so beobachten
doch der mond weist kein besonders
großes magnetfeld auf und so können die
hochenergetischen protonen ungestört mit
seiner oberfläche wechselwirken dem mond
selbst kann man sich bei diesem prozess
in etwa so wie einen natürlichen
teilchendetektor vorstellen das
mondgestein absorbiert die
gammastrahlung die die kosmischen
partikel produzieren doch nicht alles
wird absorbiert einige photonen werden
auch reflektiert und genau das hat
vernetzt beobachten können der mond ist
also somit eine indirekte quelle von
gammastrahlung denn sie entsteht
hierdurch seine wechselwirkung mit
kosmischer strahlung die studie des
italienischen forschungsteams zeigt
deutlich dass der mond deutlich mehr
gammastrahlung aussenden und als man
bisher in der fachwelt angenommen hatte
und das sind enorm wichtige erkenntnisse
für zukünftige mondmissionen die nasa
hat ja angekündigt dass um das jahr 2020
wieder astronautinnen und astronauten
zum mond und vielleicht sogar auch zum
mars geschickt werden sollen dann ist
das wissen um die hochenergetische
strahlung des mondes vielleicht
entscheidend in einer umgebung die von
gammastrahlung und kosmischer strahlung
geprägt ist ist abschirmung der
astronautinnen und astronauten sowie
eine zeitliche begrenzung der
strahlenexposition für deren gesundheit
enorm wichtig denn die kosmische
strahlung die man als astronaut und
astronauten im weltall abbekommen gilt
tatsächlich als große gefahr kein
raumschiff dieser welt kann diese
gefährliche strahlung so gut abhalten
wie ist die atmosphäre die ozonschicht
und das magnetfeld der erde tun
auf der iss der internationalen
raumstation ist das kein großes problem
weil das erdmagnetfeld einiges davon
bereits weit außen abhält bei
zukünftigen mond oder mars missionen
würde aber sicherlich kein weg daran
vorbei führen dass die besatzung eine
große strahlendosis abbekommt und fest
steht sie kann das menschliche gewebe
und nervenzellen tatsächlich schädigen
da sie selbst vor der aluminiumhülle des
raumschiffes kann
macht medizin teams zu befürchten dass
die strahlung auch andere auswirkungen
auf aus denen astronauten haben könnte
beispielsweise könnte die emotionale
stabilität und die reaktionsfähigkeit
nachlassen aber auch das krebsrisiko
steigt durch die strahlung
forschungsteams weltweit sind dabei
medikamente zu entwickeln die die
wirkung der kosmischen strahlung
abfedern könnten beispielsweise in dem
die menschlichen zellen strahlen
resistenter gemacht werden vor allem
auch die gammastrahlen sind nicht ohne
diese dringen in alle organsysteme des
körpers ein und schädigen diese atome
und moleküle werden durch diese
strahlung in unserem körper ironisiert
letztendlich werden so biochemische
reaktionen in den zellen ausgelöst die
vor allem für unser erbgut negative
folgen haben könnten
das erste verbrechen im weltraum das ist
jetzt aufgedeckt worden astro comics tv
berichtet hier darüber anklicken
anschauen und den coolen kanal
abonnieren ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran